la forêt comtoise prend bien souvent des
airs de petit paradis
et pourtant un mal ronge nos bois le
scolyte un petit insecte ravageur dévore
les épicéas dans cette parcelle de forêt
domaniale plus de 40 arbres sont déjà
condamnés c'est le bûcheron qui va venir
les couper dans les quinze jours qui
viennent il ya urgence
là faut vraiment aller vite on a pour
preuve les années les suisses où nous
les années où on n'a rien fait
l'épidémie continue x années alors même
si le prix des bois très bas
actuellement c'est le cas il faut agir
le préfet de bourgogne franche comté en
juin donc les propriétaires forestiers à
couper et à évacuer tous les épicéas
infesté une opération très coûteuse pour
des arbres dont la valeur s'est
effondrée ce désert était destiné à
faire de la tâche la tâche est ce qu'on
fabrique les boîtes à mondor le pourtour
de la boîte à mon tort c'est des armes
cda florez valu l on aurait vendu de
mètres cubes de 100 heures plus de 200
euros le mètre cube qu'à l'heure
actuelle on en est allé vendre badu the
roll matthew un manque à gagner
considérable notamment pour les très
nombreuses communes forestières à la
longeville par exemple les ventes de
bois représente un quart des recettes
municipales
pour cet élu le décret du préfet est
difficilement applicable
quand on voit le problème effectivement
d'une dépérissement très dispersées dans
la forêt sa mesure toute la difficulté
qu'il y as d'aller chercher un peu
partout ces bois scolytés à sa part est
très très difficile sans parler du
problème économique de bois qui n'ont
pas de valeur donc faux faut y aller
vraiment pour des raisons sanitaires et
c'est un impact économique non
négligeable pour forcer les communes les
obligations préfectoral seront également
difficile à mettre en oeuvre et à
contrôler chez les propriétaires privés
en fin de compte face à un insecte qui
profitent de la sécheresse pour
s'attaquer aux arbres affaiblis par le
manque d'eau c'est le retour durable de
la pluie qui sera le plus efficace pour
stopper l'épidémie